let me pull up this tweet here
Elon Musk tweeted what should Twitter do
next
originally good name says bring back
Alex Jones Elon Musk says no
the Hodge twins tweeted should Elon
bring back Alex Jones of 140 000 votes
57.7 say yes 42.3 say no
and then we have this tweet from viva
fry who makes the perfect Point Alex
Jones is the litmus test Elon Musk not
just on the issue of freedom of speech
but on the issue of not bending the knee
to political and judicial intimidation
if this is a hard no your Twitter will
never be any more trustworthy than parag
or Jack's Twitter and Elon responded too
bad
there you go
what a prick seriously if you're gonna
do something like this violate free
speech for an individual that is
controversial while allowing other
controversial voices to be on there if
you're if you're allowing Kathy Griffin
to be on there but not Alex Jones at
least explain yourself what did Alex
Jones do well he yelled at Allah for
Darcy yeah he was in he was in one of
the Congressional confronted Jack Dorsey
well he confronted his Banning was over
Oliver Darcy he put up a video where he
was calling him a rat face or something
yeah I'm not a fan of that right I can't
stand this stuff there's a lot of people
who just laugh and say no they deserve
it Alex was right and it's like I don't
care you're allowed to like that fine
it's free speech and all that but I
don't like it and I certainly don't
think he should have been banned for
doing it if you're in public and
someone's mad at you and they confront
you there was no security threat or
anything like that it was just Alex
yelling at the guy they banned him for
it Kathy Griffin held up an image of a
severed head and she didn't even get
banned for that she got like a slap on
the wrist she got banned because she
mocked Elon Musk uh parroting his
account without putting parity trying to
I guess make a point or whatever he
reinstates her but showing holding up a
severed head of the president that was
never in question she also evaded the
ban and then went on her Dead Mother's
platform in order to still raise her
voice against Elon Musk so again
something's happening here you're going
to allow her to have a voice but not not
Alex Jones explain your reasoning don't
be a prick don't just say too bad what's
going on here is there internal pressure
are there people inside of the company
that are saying no don't do this are
there corporations are there government
agencies are there any other
institutions that are pressuring you to
do this at least explain yourself if
you're going to be making this kind of
statement and Alex Jones of course
responded making his own video uh
regarding this specific news and he says
Hey guys don't blame Elon Musk here he's
Alex Jones is trying to be the bigger
person here uh addressing this larger
Saga here but but at the end of the day
we at least deserve an explanation
because we were promised Free Speech
this is not free speech this is a person
deciding what he wants with his own
whims that that shouldn't be acceptable
to anyone yeah I was going to say Alex
Jones doesn't have a choice but to be
the bigger person right if he goes on a
tirade and is mad at Elon he's like well
your family's not even that cool like he
could be like Kathy Griffin and go
nuclear and go crazy but it's okay if
she does it exactly she's a really funny
comedian you don't understand hilarious
hilarious it's the same thing with now
the 230 ruling though right of that
maybe you could make the argument that
Elon is worried that you know Alex comes
back and because he's being sued for
three trillion dollars now which is I
believe it is 3 trillion which is just a
little bit under twice is it really 3
trillion yes just a little under twice
the annual DOD uh uh I think it's three
times the GDP of France it's something
like that isn't it I just looked up
today that it's twice the the dod's
annual budget so yeah three trillion
dollars is on the table they're trying
to fund the war in Ukraine the money's
got to come from somewhere but so maybe
you could make the argument that before
this decision comes down about section
230 is that maybe Elon is worried that
well if you know they're going after
Alex Jones for for the GDP of France
that then they'll come after him in some
way but if section 230 is no longer
going to apply to make it so that you
can sue the uh platform for what someone
on it says then it doesn't make any
sense people are are bringing up that
Alex Jones issued a statement saying
Elon shouldn't bring him back he's the
most controversial person and eons going
up against everybody and so he's got to
do what he can and uh I don't care Alex
I understand what you're saying and I
get it but uh either Elon is going to
there's a couple ways he could play this
he could just not respond he could say
nothing he is choosing to come out and
outright say you know that free speech
thing I tweeted about an hour ago screw
that I don't really care so that's what
pisses me off I totally get that elon's
like dude there's only so much I can do
totally get it I respect it he just
bought this massive platform and needs
to survive it needs money to operate he
doesn't want it to die he doesn't want
to lose money on that and he wants to
actually bring Free Speech back I get it
you bring back Alex Jones they go
nuclear against you and then the whole
thing implodes he brought back Andrew
Tate Andrew Tate is back on the platform
yeah so so Highway picking and choosing
here yes what's the scale here well the
scale is Alex points out he's the most
controversial person in the world that
being said Elon did not have to come out
and insult Alex's fans like that he
could have just ignored it yeah he
didn't have to respond to anyone
tweeting on Alex's behalf too I mean he
is looking for this fight but to me I
just don't understand why like what
purpose is this serving for The Virtue
signaling I I guess but we're just
saying the advertisers so he can be like
look see I said I wouldn't bring him
back but because when he said he hadn't
made a decision on Trump or when he said
he wasn't going to bring back Jones a
bunch of leftists were like at least
there's I saw high profile leftists
journalists saying at least some sanity
and things like that he's getting
positive feedback from that which is the
first positive feedback he's gotten on
any of this however it is a slippery
slope and it's the same way they've
Fallen before versus Alex Jones and then
who who else is then not acceptable but
that's not true he's getting attacked by
the corporate media insanely everything
there's a piece after hippies after he
this is not being met with like okay
this is great this is being ignored and
they're still trying to attack him any
way that they possibly can so why are
you trying to placate these people right
is is he like trying to go over to the
FBI or BlackRock or China be like look
at me I'm a totalitarian I'm a prick too
I could do what you guys do is that what
you're doing because what else are we
left to speculate here because otherwise
there's no other rational conclusion
than him as you Tim mentioned
specifically showing off to the powers
that be saying I could play ball I could
play game uh you know just tell me what
to do and I'll follow those orders and
that's not a platform that I believe in
that's not a platform that I want to be
on I want to read the Super Chat from
old stick key taint he says voting for
Trump's unbanning is a smart move Force
the advertisers to justify why they want
to uh what do you say pause
advertisement poll advertisements when
the majority of their target audience
wants him on actually yeah that's a
really great Point what out what what
Elon needs to say to the advertisers is
you're being attacked by activists who
are lying to you and costing you money
once we get rid of those Bots you will
be able to actually Target your audience
who like people like Jones or Trump
that's probably uh probably the move
he's making in that regard they'd have
to publish or at least actually conduct
some real internal research that they
could show to their shareholders on that
and the people they're selling
advertising space there's no
shareholders or not shareholders sorry
uh selling marketing well I think
they're there's I think they do have
technically stockholders or right
because because they're there he does
have people who are holding privately
advertisements to then they would want
to be able to tell them that look that
your advertisements are being shown to
real people and that those people when
they are given internal when they're
given polls because you know you can
take these exit polls on Twitter so they
send you an email and you say would you
like to take this poll about your
experience with Twitter oh you get
Twitter blue for a month for free or
something like that so you can try it
out if you finish our survey there's all
kinds of ways to incentivize people to
give you data that you could use and
then take that and say hair to the
advertisers people say they want Trump
to this certain degree and actually have
something to to sell with them and say
it's not all Bots I tried advertising on
Twitter because I I he they're giving
the double verification everybody so I
tweeted hey Elon how much do I got to
spend to get the official tag and uh I
don't expect him actually respond to me
but so I decided to take out an ad on
our uh Trump going Super Saiyan shirt
which is available in the chat and it's
the super Maga shirt and uh so I was
gonna put a big campaign bind at 25k to
see if if it's legit and because again I
I do want to see Twitter succeed I'm not
just throwing money at Elon it's
advertising a product we sell that we
make money on that I bet if I spend this
money we're going to make more money
back they rejected it they said a
cartoon image of Donald Trump going
Super Saiyan was political
why now now that now I'm deeply offended
I just wanted to sell a t-shirt of
Donald Trump with Goku here you can't
even do that apparently
go ahead sorry oh no that was it that
was just a green how do they determine
what's political because I've only used
the promotion feature once on YouTube
and it was or not YouTube on Twitter and
it was to promote a YouTube video that
was not largely political but it was
there were politics involved in the
video so how did they determine what's
political it's Trump yeah they didn't
want a a cartoon of trump that makes him
look good they don't want to take the
money for that or something well my
video was an hour long and it was
political at some points but they I
guess didn't want to watch an hour long
video to figure that part out the image
isn't even Pro or anti-trump it's just
meant to be silly it's Trump with you
know spiky blonde hair
now there's a couple things to consider
especially with this poll with uh Elon
Musk asking if Donald Trump should be
reinstated or not because uh on October
3rd Mashable has this article that I
think is is worth revisiting right now
that's titled in Elon musk's words it
seems Twitter Bots are always to blame
now there hasn't been any kind of
Reckoning with the Bots there hasn't
been any kind of Discovery there haven't
been any kind of major Bombshells
surrounding the bots on big Tech social
media platforms especially Twitter but
Elon Musk was complaining about the Bots
after he did a poll on his own Twitter
account specifically on October 3rd
asking if there should be a Ukrainian
Russian peace deal after their response
he specifically said this is the biggest
bot attack I've ever seen so why after
not dealing with the Bots are we
deciding if the former president of the
United States who's running to be
president in 2024 will be able to have
any kind of speech also if you remember
he also tweeted earlier today that he
believes in the policy of freedom of
speech no he doesn't it but he says he
does but he doesn't believe in the
freedom of reach and he says negative
content is going to be de-boosted
demonetized what's negative content what
who's going to be determining what's
negative what's positive again
everything here is arbitrary there's no
baselines there's no rules he's
following along and doing horrible
things like not allowing free speech on
the platform which he promised which
everyone now feels backstabbed about and
that's that idiom that you see people on
the left use so commonly of oh freedom
of speech doesn't mean freedom from
consequences so it's basically coming
down to the same kind of thing I feel
like at this point everyone should just
tweet at Elon Musk like get it give us a
timeline on the bot situation like
didn't Ann Coulter have like a countdown
every day that Donald Trump didn't like
do something about the wall like where
is our like the Bots are gone countdown
because it I mean to both of your points
Elon Musk is putting out polls and then
saying they're being hacked by bot so
you already told us it was problem and
also how are you supposed to give
accurate data to any advertisers if
they're always being if you can say at
any time oh the Bots got to this I mean
you would think that ideally if he is
working in true capitalism and he wants
to make as much money as possible he
would be hounding his staff to deal with
the Bots or are the Bots a problem that
can't be solved that's why I asked
earlier like do you think he made a
mistake buying Twitter like is this
platform and I'm not a tech person but
is it so corrupted the Bots are
something that can't be removed at this
point you can't purge them fast enough
at this point would it be better to
abandon ship and move on to something
else even though you can't bring the
people with you a complete user
verification would do something maybe to
help with them but he's not doing that
but he's not gonna do and and also I I
think that you're going to lose a lot of
people will leave the platform if you
require someone to although you need to
have a phone number you don't need to
force everyone it's if you want
verification you got to use a real
picture a real name so we verified you I
thought when he was talking about a
verification he was going to verify
everyone the same way we have to be
verified either a brand account that
confirms they are the corporation and
it's really hard to do some I I don't
know if uh Twitter does it this way but
you have to like send him a photo of
your Articles of Incorporation with like
your ID showing that you are the officer
because they're verifying you for
everyone else you can use different
photos and stuff but typically you have
to be the person you're verified to be
Milo yiannopoulos lost his verification
because he included in his bio BuzzFeed
journalist or something like that they
said up but you're impersonating
verification removed so Elon comes in
and he's like you can have a badge you
want it so bad for eight dollars and
then he just verifies everyone then when
that implodes he's like I'll just give a
second verification to Big Brands and
that's what my point was okay what
constitutes worthiness for getting
verified twice
I know it's confusing and it's weird
being on the platform seeing double
verification only the corporate media
which again Elon knows Elon knows the
corporate media runs scams if we're
going to be fighting this information if
we're going to be getting rid of Contra
controversial figures that spread
disinformation CNN needs to be gone from
the platform immediately MSNBC needs to
be gone from the platform immediately
and and they're not so if we're going to
not allow Alex Jones for you know
allegedly being misinformation he got
something's wrong obviously we could
criticize everyone I've criticized him
before but at the end of the day you you
take his record and you take it to the
corporate media he has told far more
truths than of course the corporate
media that's routinely lying to the
American people and running larger
psyopsis against them thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time